Donald Trump has pleaded not guilty to
the 37 charges that he is facing he has
returned to Bedminster New Jersey he
will be speaking in about 15 minutes
from now so we will be uh pulling that
up and playing his his speech but we do
have a lot of big culture War news to
begin with Starbucks according to their
Union has ordered Pride decorations be
removed from any of their locations now
outright the story was that they said
take it all down we're shutting this
down in Miller pride month a
spokesperson for Starbucks is denying it
they're saying they have no such policy
in place
and I got a business I don't believe him
I think that it is it is more likely
that Starbucks is reacting to the
boycott new information coming out about
Bud Light their sales are down again not
another week on and we're seeing Target
take another massive hit their their
market cap is dropping I think Starbucks
and many other companies are seeing this
and they're saying okay we better we
better back off but now that the union
is making it a big deal during pride
month they're getting a little worried
we'll break down that story and then we
got more interesting news last night in
the members only section we talked about
a trans influencer who went topless at
the White House during a pride event
with two other trans uh personalities
sparking a major backlash that actually
resulted in the president uh the White
House I should say the administration
denouncing the activists and banning
them from the White House for future
events I think this is tremendous this
is a shift the behavior that we see at
all these Pride parades that we're
critical of lewd behavior in front of
children the White House has condemned
and banned someone over so I think we
should be absolutely saying okay let's
let's see more of this so let's uh we'll
get into all this and then of course
we'll be pulling up Donald Trump's
speech before we do my friends head over
to castbrew.com and buy our coffee our
coffee Casper coffee is delicious I
gotta be honest it really is I'm really
impressed we got samples made we sent
them out to us we formulated the Blends
that we liked go to castbrew.com join
our cast Brew Coffee club and you'll get
three different bags every single month
or you can just buy outright we've got
rise with Roberto Jr with every purchase
of rise with Roberto Jr you get a
picture of our rooster Roberto Jr right
there on the back of the bag and of
course we have Appalachian nights what I
have right here support our work because
we sponsor ourselves and we're going to
be launching a bunch of coffee shops so
really do appreciate all of your support
also make sure you go to timcast.com in
fact I don't actually have to do I have
timcast.com pulled up here normally I do
I think oh here we go go to timcast.com
click join us to become a member and
support our work directly we're gonna
have members only on members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight at 10 pm where you can actually
call in and talk to us and our guests so
uh definitely become a member and
support us
you can smash the like button subscribe
to the channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Lisa Welch hi
guys thanks for having me back happy to
be here who are you oh um I'm like a
former Health staffer writer producer
kind of thing and now I work for Tim
cast that's right that's right for this
awesome show called the culture war and
so if um you wanna if you're a liberal
answer your DMs please so uh basically
this is this is a a a special
announcement I suppose we for the
culture War podcast we do on Fridays
youtube.com timcast we are going to be
ramping up to uh our earlier goal which
is we're going to have left and right
liberal conservative libertarian liberal
libertarian conservative whatever you
name it socialist commies having these
conversations and we've actually got one
planned not for this week but the next
week is going to be a really fascinating
conversation we've got a prominent
liberal personality coming on with a
more moderate personality plus I'll be
there uh involved in the conversation
and and uh moderating and then we're
going to be having many of these
I guess I don't call them debates but
you know debatish style conversations
between people across the political
aisle so it'll be really fun and Lisa is
going to be helping put all that stuff
together yeah I'm super excited also
right on we got Sheamus hanging out my
name is Seamus Coughlin I make cartoons
I have a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we're going to be releasing a
video this Thursday I think you all are
going to love we had a tremendous
performance this last Thursday in terms
of views on the video it went to our
first video out of the last 10 the
audience really seemed to like that so I
want to thank you all for tuning in and
suggest all of you go check it out if
you haven't seen it and we're working on
something about Trump's trial for this
Thursday so it's going to be a fun one I
want to ask you all to go over to the
channel and subscribe hey guys Ian
Crossland and I just wanted to give you
a little uh little hint a little uh
little life hack if when you're typing
in a web address hold down control and
press enter and it'll fill in www
and.com for you so you never have to
type W's and comms all that crap again
just control enter type of word control
enter it'll load it for you oh wow yep
wow saved a lot of time I didn't know
that and I used to do web design so
thanks Ian I appreciate it what's up
guys serve.com let's get to it before uh
so in about 10 or so minutes Trump will
be speaking but before we get to that
let's jump to this story we have this
tweet from the Starbucks Workers United
saying breaking in the middle of pride
month Starbucks bands Pride decorations
and stores across the United States now
according to community notes and a few
other articles there's a spokesperson
saying it is not true they have no
change to their corporate policy
regarding regarding displays for Pride
or any other Heritage Month interesting
we continue to encourage our store
leaders to celebrate with their
communities including U.S pride month in
June I don't believe him why
for one thing you're the actual workers
pointing out they're experiencing this
and they're hearing from it's the union
saying that they're hearing from their
workers I think the ideologically
motivated activists are more likely to
be outraged the decorations are coming
down and the corporation is more worried
about a financial backlash to people
finding out their backtracking but
there's actually a much simpler reason I
don't believe the corporation there are
videos of people in Starbucks taking
down the decorations and saying they
were told to take down the decorations
according to Twitter Twitter thread
Starbucks Workers United said for the
last two weeks Starbucks workers have
taken a social media to report the
company is no longer allowing Pride
decorations in store this seems to be
the first year the publicly Pro lgbtq
company has taken this kind of stance
taking a cue from Target who bowed to
anti-lgbtq pressure and removed Pride
merchandise corporate and District
management are taking down the pride
decorations that have become an annual
tradition in stores in Union stores
where Starbucks claims they are unable
to make unilateral changes without
bargaining The company took down Pride
decorations and flags anyway ignoring
their own anti-union talking point
Starbucks is powered by many queer
workers but management has failed to
materially support the LGBT community
last October some workers have reported
that their transgender Benefit Plan
changed if Starbucks was a true Ally
they would stand up for us especially
during a time when LGBT people are under
attack a company that cares wouldn't
turn their back true allyship with the
community is negotiating a Union
contract etc etc
well the update to the new Republic
article is that they are denying the
allegations but they're there actually
are videos here we have this video on uh
okay it's gonna make me I'm not gonna I
don't wanna open Tick Tock it's uh they
they did post videos on the article
maybe I can play it this way
there we go
you've got people in Starbucks taking
down Pride Flags so you can see them
taking the flags down you know so when I
see a video like that I'm and and
there's there's like three or four
others that uh that they played I'm kind
of like yeah I it probably makes sense
that Starbucks is saying take this stuff
down and it may be that all of these
companies are taking major Financial
hits the White House is even condemning
trans activists for their behavior that
we see typical at Pride events it seems
like there is a major shift in the
culture War yeah Corporate America is
scared and I think the elite are
actually starting to become frightened
that they've pushed this on us too
quickly that doesn't mean they've given
up that doesn't mean they've won it just
means that some of them are going to be
a little bit softer with their messaging
for a little while but Starbucks doing
this is quite significant because this
is the place where beautiful people do
important creative things on their
MacBooks and so as the urbanite and uh
brilliant forward-thinking cosmopolitans
who make up their consumer base or who
are their ideal customers to be less
important to them than the massive
public backlash that they fear might
befall them as occurred uh to Target and
Bud Light is an unbelievably beautiful
thing I mean there is real Market
pressure here and I have to say this is
not something I predicted I remember
when people stopped buying Bud Light I
was cautiously optimistic but I was a
little bit worried that it might fall
off and now this is this is trickled all
the way down to Starbucks I mean how
wonderful when you think of liberals you
think of Starbucks exactly that is
exactly what you think of and so that
means what the what the conservatives
are doing is working we're finally doing
something that's working this means we
should go harder keep it up never let
down I just I just kind of think it's
much simpler than that I I I I I don't
want to say it's not working but I think
conservatives are just in the front of
the way of Surfing this this this energy
right Starbucks I'm sorry Target was
already dealing with backlash before
conservatives even brought it up
something changed you know I think it is
I think for the longest time you have
pride parades nobody cares they say I
don't go to those parades I don't care
if you do them then they they have pride
merchandise at stores and they're like
don't know don't care my family doesn't
even know anything about it do your
thing then one day their kid comes home
with a book from school talking about
adult Concepts and showing them graphic
pictures and now they're saying is that
what they've been doing yeah wow and so
then when they walked into a Target they
went no no no no no no I saw those books
now we're seeing the same thing with
Starbucks finally people are saying
you've stepped Over The Line This is the
crazy thing if they just kept it we're
going to have our celebration and we're
going to mind our own business nothing
would happen nothing would change but as
soon as they started introducing it to
children now it's taken the whole thing
down but even with the parades and the
celebrations they've like upped the ante
there is rampant degeneracy there are
naked people
um like illegal lewd nudity sex acts Etc
especially yeah exactly and in front of
children oftentimes like you know these
are on major city streets and even if
you're not there to go to the pride
parade but if you have to take your kid
to the doctor and you have to walk down
the street that that that's on the break
round like your kid you they are forcing
your children to interact with them
Non-Stop and I think the parents have
had enough I've had enough well look the
question is do we want to create a
culture where it is safe for children to
be outside in broad daylight with their
parents where they won't be likely to
see anything sexually perverse or do we
want to make this a country where
perverts are free to wear leather half
naked in the streets that's the question
in your average American who is not
necessarily on the right is saying I
prefer a country where children aren't
going to see that when they step outside
you kind of want a balance because a
hundred years ago men weren't allowed to
wear go shirtless good it was illegal uh
because of decency laws to have a no
shirt on you couldn't wear shirts yeah
and it was like no it could be shirtless
yeah yeah
interesting then take your shirts off I
would rather go back to not being able
to see women's ankles right like
literally not being able to see women's
ankles than what it is now
but you're right you're right no like
let's be real let's be real I I prefer
some uh some good old classical and
traditional liberalism you know people
want to dress the way they dress as long
as not lewd and obscene so you can wear
shorts you can women can wear uh you
know gym shorts and go jogging whatever
they're wearing but you have to cover
your ankles with socks no no but if you
if you're gonna tell me my choice is
between going back to puritanical no
ankles or that video we saw out of West
Hollywood where two adult men performed
a sex acts on each other in front of
children I'd be like yeah ban all of it
no ankles yeah like I will gladly wear
two layers in the summer no child was
was ever traumatized or abused because
they couldn't see someone's ankle right
think about this guy as a woman right do
you know how hard it is for me to even
buy a bathing suit that covers your
entire backside like they're almost
non-existent my kids are at they're like
I'm on the beach with my father my
brother my two children and they are
looking at girls butts all day long like
it's like there's nothing wrong with it
the whole like all of society has gone
way off the rails and they're like oh
that's fine I even see girls in the
conservative movement they're on like
religious holiday trips and they're in
thong
bathing suits yeah or at least like you
know the ones that are almost a thong
like what are we what are we what are we
doing here I that I understand like
there's a line and it gets it the line
keeps being pushed upon I don't I don't
mind bathing suits the issue is though
you know like Ian you're just saying
it's like Sharia almost look man we talk
about this when it comes to abortion if
my choice is a pro-life candidate who
says there's we should we should
restrict abortion outright I go I don't
know if I agree with that then I look
over to the left and they say something
like we should have people getting
abortions at nine months and I'm like no
we should get rid of that what are my
options my option is literally just the
one who who stops that and that this is
what the left doesn't seem to understand
this is why I think Starbucks made this
move this is why I think these
corporations are making this move
because they're they're right now the
the bifurcation of culture has split
dramatically where the traditional
liberals in this country who are like
we're totally cool with pride flags are
now saying I don't want to have to
explain to my kid why those two adult
men were doing a sex act in public just
get rid of it so now it's like pride
month is out because we you've crossed
the line well I think Lisa you touched
on something very important when you
were discussing having trouble finding a
modest bathing suit which is that as
soon as something becomes normalized it
almost invariably becomes the new status
quo and then that ends up being forced
onto everybody else so it's rarely an
option between uh tyranny and freedom
with these left-wing social causes in
fact with the left that's never the
choice it's almost always you're going
to have reasonable restrictions or you
are actually going to be forced to
support or even engage in licentiousness
and degeneracy I used to wonder about
that how a girl could go outside with a
thong bikini on and not get arrested for
public indecency because I could see her
full butt yeah like well that's just
naked almost right yeah you can't just
put a piece of thread through your butt
crack and pretend like you're not naked
where are the morals amen my father like
I don't want to be with my father on a
beach yeah with with girls and their
butts hanging out like that makes me
uncomfortable don't these people have
any self-respect or or don't they have
any care for their their family and
they're oh it's just gross there are
nude beaches I don't think kids are
supposed to go to those then that's
because you get you know your your skin
sunlight is really healthy for your skin
so you have a backyard everybody's got
some of a backyard that would be ideal
city people not in cities I mean I live
in the city and if I really need to do
then I can make it happen I'm just
saying but I don't need to do that by
the water it's really really healthy all
that sun that uh salt water we're gonna
see a pendulum swing back in the other
direction because it's gone too far
there's been there's been tons of
Tolerance there's there's been a ton of
Live and Let Live and that's why at the
beach people are wearing basically
whatever they want but now it's getting
to the point where look the the the I
don't think most people to this day I
think most people still don't care that
women are in bikinis at the beach and
that guys are wearing speedos or
whatever if they do most people still
don't care what happens is you get to
the line where there are people in
parades
the these two adult men this is the
viral video there's also the video of
the guy
um shoving his butt up for the child
with a mom laughs like as soon as that
happens the damn breaks yeah the straw
breaks the camel's back and then regular
people regular Bulls say enough this is
getting out of hand it's got to stop
yeah it's the sex sacks that are too
much if you went to a beach and people
were in a bikini and uh you know what
you were saying like a dude in a speedo
but they were pretending to get it on
like doggy stuff you know that would not
fly people the cops would be like you're
under arrest for public indecency you
can't simulate sex in front of kids on
the beach like at a pride parade you can
but apparently this is like a a place in
society where there's been a loophole uh
for some reason Tim's right though but
yeah so I I'm on Instagram and of course
their algorithms favor the things that I
like but I have noticed like really
floral and feminine dresses coming back
that are more modest in nature long
right they're they're they're selling
and they're selling out the racks for
like 300 bucks and they're only sold out
right like there's tons of them and I'm
seeing more and more people talk about
wanting to Homestead and I think the
pendulum is starting to swing which is
the only thing that's really given me
and it is it is uh I'd like to start
this story off by giving a shout out to
Joe Biden thank you President Joe Biden
NBC news says White House bans trans
activist for a topless photo at Pride
event it was a video Rose Montoya a
trans model activist said she was living
her truth and wasn't trying to be vulgar
or profane
but in fact that's exactly what this
person was doing jumping up and down
topless with two other trans individuals
and exposing their their bare chests now
you can make the argument that it's
legal to do so in in Washington DC sure
under the 14th Amendment if men are
allowed to go out without shirts on then
women are as well but this is the White
House this is a formal event
this is an individual who showed up
took their top off and all that stuff
let me just read the story we'll get
into it the White House said a
transgender model would be banned from
future events due to photos and videos
that show her topless in the South lawn
during an lgbtq pride month celebration
on Saturday that's individual just for
clarification is biologically male Rose
Montoya a trans-modeling activist was
among hundreds invited by Biden Montoya
shared a video from the event on
Instagram that features a clip of first
standing in front of the White House
topless covering her nipples with her
hands right-wing media shared
screenshots from montoya's video with
commentators and media personalities
calling her actions disrespectful well
the White House spokesperson said
Tuesday that Montoya and the other
people featured would be banned from
future events organized there this
behavior is inappropriate and
disrespectful for any event at the White
House it is not reflective of the event
we hosted to celebrate lgbtqi families
or other hundreds of guests who were in
attendance
the White House spokesperson said
individuals in the video will not be
invited to future events now Candace
Owens has been critical of Biden for
inviting these people knowing full well
what these people do I can agree with
that however I think we should be
praising the Biden Administration Kareem
Jean-Pierre and all of the Democrats in
the white house right now for this why
this behavior that we're seeing is
commonplace at Pride parades and pride
events in fact substantially worse
things go on correct if this was a pride
event
and this is inappropriate and
unacceptable and warranting a ban for
more than one individual and that's Joe
Biden who said it well that's wonderful
two things we want Joe Biden Democrats
in the establishment to back off this
stuff to lose that fight we want these
people to quite literally say Sheamus
you were right the whole time we're
sorry and now we agree with you and
that's exactly what Joe Biden is is
starting with it with this process in
doing so the Democrats are now agreeing
with us we're winning that fight why am
I going to complain about it the most
important thing is in terms of how we
address the conversation the next time
to each and every one of you people out
there listening with your liberal aunt
or or uh you know family member who is
always telling you you're wrong now you
only need say one thing look I I don't
know about all that but I agree with Joe
Biden on this one this stuff is
inappropriate and and is disrespectful
that's it so now when they say oh you
Trump is no no I'm with Joe Biden on
this one you know Joe Biden came out his
administration saying this stuff
shouldn't be happening he's right come
on man I'm Catholic we don't believe in
that this is indecent but it creates a
tribal conundrum for many of these
individuals if their whole identity is
just hating Trump but now all of a
sudden you their supposed political
enemy is saying no Biden was right
what's their response going to be
Biden's wrong okay absolutely get them
to start condemning Joe Biden yeah I
absolutely agree with you I do think
though it is also important to point out
the hypocrisy of them like like Candace
said she like you know who you're
inviting so yeah you know that this is
moral indecent you just admitted it and
yet you avoided them anyway knowing that
they were likely to behave like they
behave at all other Pride events what's
wrong with you let me let me show you
these tweets uh uh because I think
there's actually a good exchange between
uh Candace and myself Candace Owen says
Rose Montoya is the name of the man who
exposed his surgically created breasts
to young children at the White House the
White House invited rose knowing fully
well that he advocates for the teaching
of sex to young children he advocates
for this openly on his Instagram page
now I I disagree with that sentiment and
and I responded you should be praising
Biden he actually condemned trans
activists and uh Candace responded
you're missing the point entirely Biden
is only condemning this act because his
voters were outraged he invited this
individual to the White House knowing
what this individual was and exactly how
they behaved in public his entire
Instagram is dedicated to debauchery I
said after realizing it was hurting him
he backtracked now his RPI response now
you praised Biden in order to push the
story and force him to keep condemning
the Behavior now we say this LGBT Pride
stuff where they danced naked at parades
is bad I agree with Joe Biden that's my
point by all means I certainly
understand what Candace is saying the
Biden Administration these these
individuals know who they're inviting
what they do but what you need to
understand about many of these people is
their fair weather politicians if they
see in public people saying it's good
they say sure fine whatever but then all
of a sudden they engage in the behavior
and it goes bad and they're getting a
big backlash
if the only options you present towards
the bite Administration Democrats
liberals or whatever is always no matter
what you do we're mad at you then
they'll just write you off if you say
you know what I disagree with you on
politics I think the Biden family is
deeply corrupt but in this in this one
thank you for doing the right thing and
condemning this Behavior
If this means they faced a backlash um
if Joe Biden faced a backlash among his
voters that was so severe he actually
condemned this that means we are winning
and this kind of loot behavior is now
being condemned by the president like
that's culture War Victory like the one
of the best we've seen now you can go to
each and every one of those liberal
family members and friends and be like
look even Joe Biden's calling this out
will you now take take a second to
listen to me I think it's victory I
think I say thanks Biden I appreciate it
I really I really sincerely mean it it
was the right thing to do I absolutely
see it as a victory too after he
denounced it or just about it absolutely
it's a it's a moral Victory because any
time that they continue to like be half
naked you can say that's wrong it's not
good enough for the White House it's not
good enough for my kids school but but
it's just it was a pride event this
person went topless and Biden said this
is wrong and disrespectful and you know
what he's absolutely correct about that
is wrong and disrespectful that I think
the big issue as to why this this debate
is happening is is because people don't
want this stuff around kids
and and and that's it
when Bud Light thought thought they were
winning they absolutely sponsored these
events it hurt them Target it hurt them
calls it's hurting them North Face it's
hurting them all these companies are now
facing this massive backlash the White
House it's hurting them all this massive
cultural shift it's like it's like
victories around the corner man I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna look a gift horse in
the mouth you know what I mean like Joe
Biden's coming out being like I guess
you guys win I'm like that's right you
were right the whole time I used to
think that Puritans were so far behind
the the curve but now I'm realizing in
real time how how Society can become
aberrant I've never seen it in my life
I'm 44 and I never saw like real
like derogatory Behavior take mainstream
attention it's always been like yeah
blackout drunk that's disgusting drug
addicts gross uh sex in public
disgusting like I knew that stuff
but now like I see why the peer why
people are Puritans in general like you
do need to protect people's minds it
can't just just because something is
real it doesn't mean it's okay to see I
wanna I wanna address some of what
people are saying real quick sorry okay
go ahead go ahead uh we've got uh some
super chats one says don't praise them
they only did it because of the Uproar
another person says don't praise your
enemies you're not gonna teach them
anything
in in any conflict
the end result is not the eradication of
of your enemy and in some instances
that's what they try to make happen for
sure you know genocide has existed
throughout history it's horrifying but
in most wars it is the subjugation of
your rival someone declares One Another
Country what do they do they occupy that
country and then use the people of their
country towards their ends it is not
just like they go in there and say now
we will remove these people like
certainly it's happened but that's not
typical
in terms of uh only doing it after
uproar that's what we want to happen
someone does something bad we say rabble
rabble rabble they say okay we're sorry
we say thank you and then we continue
through it's like you've claimed the
battlefield they've surrendered and laid
down their arms and said you win and we
go okay now the battlefield is ours now
we're going to dictate the terms in
terms of you know not praising or
anything he says don't praise your
enemies you crush them
when we get to the point where all of
these corporations are agreeing with us
in order to make them continue agreeing
with us we now must give them positive
incentive we said what you're doing is
bad they said screw you we said it's bad
we're not going to buy your products now
we stop buying their products now
they're they're markets tanking and
they're panicking if we don't buy their
products what will they do they'll say
okay we're gonna double down now is the
opportunity to say hey wow you know
these companies are are backtracking
give them an incentive to sell to you
and they will shift even further in your
direction so I know to a lot of people
it may seem counterintuitive because
you're angry at what many of these
corporations were doing and what Biden
has done and is doing and it's not just
about the culture War but you've gotta
you've got a plan for how you actually
win this and what your end goals are
going to be if the if we truly want
these people to stop targeting kids and
stop the loot and lascivious behavior in
public and in schools we have to utilize
the the this the statement from the
president we have to use it I wonder oh
we're gonna say this it's a step in the
right direction but it also so I see
what you're saying it's a step in the
right direction and we want to encourage
like good behavior like with any
children you want to encourage good
behavior but it's not it's not it's only
a piece of it for the rest of it like
they knew this guy promotes you know
being degenerate in front of children
and they invited him like where's the
apology for that are you just
apologizing person took a shirt off
right is that the only reason that the
apology is there
three people taking their shirt off and
the white house but is it where is the
outrage and the apology for inviting
these people that you that you knew were
degenerate to begin with and and
Advocate it for things that most of the
country disagrees where's where's that I
don't think you're gonna get that yeah
not from the White House not from a
political power they'll they'll ban the
enemy the enemies
it's a good start but we have to get to
the other it's we can't declare I don't
know I agree it's not about declaring
Victory it's about there's two paths the
the Democrats can go down right now and
corporations and everyone it is doubling
down on their behaviors like Bud Light
is currently doing or it's saying okay
we were wrong and going the direction
the only way someone will change their
their life their work
the only way that they'll change the
thing they're fighting for is if there
is a path of least resistance and a and
a light at the end of the tunnel if you
create a roadblock in front of them no
matter what they do they will keep doing
what they're doing it's just there's
there there's no other it's just simple
logic you you say to the Biden
Administration I hate you and you're
wrong they're gonna be like what was the
point of apologizing we got nothing for
it it made us look worse now everyone's
mad at us just keep doing what you're
doing and latch on to the fans you have
yeah if we come out we say no you're
doing a good job they're gonna be like
hey we're winning over people by doing
this let's keep doing more of it right
we want them to try to win our approval
so we have to offer that like I said I
agree incentive just to keep up with the
kid but it's to me that's like we still
have to we still have to keep pushing
them further and further and further
yeah I would agree I mean I think we
have to let people know what they're not
getting so you're right that there's an
apology here but then there's also a
question of well is he addressing the
fact that he did invite this person who
was promoting horrible stuff in the
first place right I mean there wasn't an
apology for that and you're right that
we're probably not going to get one I
just think it's important for people to
know that you haven't gotten that right
they haven't made this right they've
pushed a little bit in the right
direction but it's they're there are a
lot of bad people who get invited to the
White House the first question right now
that we can address is the behavior at
the White House yeah and it's really
there may be someone who's done
something horrendous and they got
invited after the fact and it certainly
has happened with a lot of people like
Obama invited certain people uh there's
a lot of people we could name that uh oh
we can talk about the Weather
Underground for instance and these
people who have sorted past and Trump
invited Milo I mean they're they're
questionable people that get invited who
have done who have done things the
question is first and foremost
were they was it proper decorum for the
White House and the fact that they're
saying no to this means we now have the
opportunity to say if it's not good for
the White House why is it good for the
public streets if he was upset that it
was in front of kids here why not why
not be upset that was in front of kids
elsewhere this is this is it right here
man now when it comes to the schools if
someone says why why do you care so much
about what's going on in these schools
and I'll be like I just look I agree
with Biden on this one they shouldn't be
showing kids this stuff this is so good
for ads though for Republican ads they
should have the slogan remember how
everybody was saying bring back decency
to the White House by having Biden come
in and say this is your decency and show
the White House and and like a
background picture with the zipper marks
and the yeah with the fake boobs and say
this is this is what you voted for this
is decency brought back to the light and
what is Biden going to say and what is
Biden say I already said I was sorry man
but this is you can't run on that but no
but he will say this and then the
response will be so did you not vet the
individuals or did you know and regret
it after the fact but but that is true I
think conservatives are going to this is
this is it for 2024. no no question they
are going to run these ads in Suburban
districts targeting women relentlessly
it will work it's going to be Suburban
moms who are going to be like I am
outraged that this happened this is not
decency in fact it's worse than Trump
they said Trump was the lewd old man and
he was he was pottymouth but it was
Biden who brought the people to come in
and take their shirts off and jiggle
them in front of a camera and that's the
thing people miss about Biden
intentionally so in the media is it's
not like we went from Trump who is
abrasive and angry and mean to people to
Biden who's nice and sweet we just got
someone who is equal believe not more
abrasive and mean but way less funny
right Biden did not bring decency to the
White House he's just very creepy he's
very gross and he's also very mean there
was nothing decent or adult about him in
his entire career yeah I don't I do want
to I'll point out real quick uh
Trump was supposed to speak at 8 15.
they pushed at 8 30. they pushed to 8
45. so uh making them wait D well you
know he's gotta he's coming back and
he's doing his thing so uh you know well
I feel like that's a typical Trump I
can't remember the last time he was on
time for anything I think he wants he's
loving it but uh let me I think I closed
the article let me let me try and pull
this back up this is important so let's
talk about the next big story here my
friends I'm gonna start right away with
this article from the new Republic that
we did Cover but this is important
context when I scroll down I want to see
if they if they kept their horrifying
and ridiculous statement on right-wing
rage read this it says it would be
understandable for Starbucks to suddenly
grow wary of overt Pride displays
considering how bad right-wing rage has
become Target stores in five different
states received bomb threats over the
weekend and had to be evacuated Liars
but there had been no such Fury directed
at Starbucks now hold on there a minute
the new Republic is outright lying yep
the bomb threats came from left Wingers
who were upset that Target pulled their
uh their pride merchandise and we have
this story from I believe we have daily
wire First Multiple Target stores across
U.S hit with bomb threats for quote
betraying the lgbtq plus Community
according to our port and if you don't
trust the daily wire let me bring up the
Washington Post who reports the exact
same thing news outlets in Vermont New
Hampshire New York received the same
threatening email Saturday according to
South Burlington Police Chief Sean uh
police chief Sean Burke the message
which accused Target of betraying the
lgbtq community named a store in South
Burlington Vermont and once in
Plattsburgh New York and in a Keene and
West Lebanon New Hampshire
for the new Republic to call that
right-wing rage this is what the left
does they're lying to you well they
didn't technically live so they did
because it's a different sentence they
say the first sentence is considering
how uh how the the right wing rage had
become end of thought new thought Target
stores in a different location receive
bomb threats and yeah
they have to do a different paragraph
they're literally technically you have
to do a different paragraph if you
actually want to say this is an
unrelated different thought so so
it's not referencing the rage in the
second season it is Ian uh I I encourage
you to go back to fifth grade grammar
and study uh oh I'm a grammar Nazi my
man so let's talk about paragraph
structure and what the intent of a
paragraph is and why a paragraph
contains multiple sentences right if
your first sentence lays out the premise
the second sentence is a part of the
premise of the first sentence of your
paragraph it's it's it's it's adding on
to whys they might be where so they are
quite literally calling the bomb threats
right-wing rage no they're not literally
doing that they literally are yes
it's it's not what else is a normal
person going to get out of that again
let's be real what is the intent there
the intent they're going to be
manipulated and think it is right so
that's their intent so if that is their
intent then they're lying so if it's not
a lie though it's a different kind of
manipulation than lying it it is alive
let's give them false insinuation I'm
not sure yes it's all semantic it's so
this sentence Target stores in five
different states we're seeing bomb
threats over the weekend and had to be
evacuated that sentence isolated and of
itself is a is a fact statement if you
add a sentence before it which is an
opinion changing the context of the
later information your intention is to
prevent is to present misinformation to
individuals your intention is to present
false information to a person so they
believe false things
that's as simple as it can be put they
are lying and so this is what really
happened what really happened is this
has been some this has been ongoing and
the the the attacks are either are
rather sophisticated at first when we
got the news so I I think I was in we're
hanging out as Memorial Day weekend
we're hanging out in Charleston West
Virginia I get a text asking me if this
is true CBS posted an email that was to
us we had never received that email we
checked never received it so how did
someone else get an email that said two
members at timcast we have no idea but
we did see we did get something not the
same but similar and so we forward it to
our security company I believe they're
having law enforcement take care of it I
don't know you know what else is going
on beyond that but at first I said this
seems like a hoax like someone's trying
to smear the left like a false flag to
make them seem violent or whatever
upon further investigation and further
reading my conclusion was likely that's
a bit too out it's a bit too assumptive
it may seem like it's possible but it's
speculative in the absence of evidence
the solution that makes the least amount
of assumptions tends to be correct Ergo
it's likely just a left Winger we know
their MO has been violence and Terror we
know they've used fire bombs we they you
have the song the famous song baby I'm
an anarchist where they say it's time to
throw bricks through Starbucks when it
came time to throw breakthrough through
a Starbucks window you left me all alone
referring to liberals we know that their
their MO has always been violence and
political Terror to get what they want
Target was the only major corporation to
pull back
on Pride
Bud Light doubled down Cole said nothing
North Face had nothing Nike said nothing
Target pulls the products back instantly
gets slammed with threats from someone
claiming to be from the left I think The
Simple Solution here is the correct one
the left is pissed that this company
backed down and so they're resorting to
their typical tactic unfortunately what
we learned from 2020 is that Target is
actually willing to risk or even sustain
real damage to their locations in order
to not say things that they think will
upset the market now unfortunately if
one of these lunatics actually does set
a bomb off or commit some other
terroristic act of violence people could
get hurt people could die however that's
not on target that's on whatever lunatic
does this I do want to point out
the title of the Washington Post article
Target stores see more bomb threats over
Pride Merchants wrong that's wrong it's
it's over them removing private
merchandise but you see how they're
lying yeah yeah over Pride merchandise
just such a manipulative uh that is an
outright lie they did not see bomb
threats over Pride merchandise they
didn't they they saw it exactly they saw
bomb they did not get bomb threats for
the pride merchandise they got bomb
threats for removing the fight
exact opposite yeah it should say over
lack of Pride merchandise
and get this the the writer of this
article Waits until around the the
second third uh until around 60 70
through the story before mentioning that
it was actually lgbtq people who who
were claiming to have done it this is
how the media lies it is a lie that
headline is factually false and how many
people are going to see that headline
and share it and say this is why we're
not safe in this country the right wing
is coming after us we know that they do
this all the time though they do this
with absolutely everything they make up
these fake things things that happen and
then they say oh this community they're
the most at risk from right-wing
extremism if it was if this really
happened and this was a republican like
or a right-wing person you would a
hundred thousand percent you would know
the person's name they would be arrested
tomorrow we don't still don't know who
the Gen six bombers are right but you
would know who called in that bomb
threat if it was a right-wing person
that was doing that to Target you would
100 know every time it will not have the
word terrorism in the title and not only
that every other brand on the planet
would be saying we stand in solidarity
with Target or there would be some kind
of Nationwide movement to acknowledge
this and have an open dialogue which is
another way of saying a lecture from the
LGBT community about how special and
good they are and how bad and nasty we
are for not accepting their lifestyle
choices
yep well it looks legit to me that the
actual threat was from who they say they
were I don't know could be a false flag
if someone's smart smart enough and
intelligence isn't always an indication
of Good and Evil like an evil person can
be intelligent and some evil intelligent
person wanted to
create a false flag and make it look
like the LGBT community was striking out
because their materials were removed
well nice job you succeeded I mean it
really feels like angered people lash
out that's what they do I mean I don't
know what else to I just chanted a
little Jordan Peterson it's like man if
that's what you're doing you better for
you you accomplished it you're doing
that then cut it out man it's not good
if it is not right do not do it if it is
not true do not say it amen
but this is where we're at but is that
true it's it's it's true enough and uh
it's faster pressure but look the the
the article from the new Republic this
was about Starbucks backtracking
if we start seeing Starbucks get similar
treatment we'll know exactly what's
going on far left extremists this is
their uh this is their MO I think this
is what they do I think that the fervor
is petered out on this now this pride
month it lasted a couple weeks people
know they don't need to push it so hard
like the real people that care about the
health and safety of people in different
marginalized communities don't want to
put their marginalized Community out
front and center because it just it gets
Stones thrown you don't want that
um so I think that any kind of it's the
activists that have been trying to
create some sort of political movement
that are getting their metaphorical
behinds whooped and getting kicked out
of uh the White House banned from the
White House like you don't need to
it's one thing to be accepted it's
another thing to try and change society
to to fit your world view that's not
where we're I feel like you're giving
people a lot of credit because most of
the people that I know with the
exception of you they don't just want to
be accepted and tolerated they want to
be celebrated they want to have a leg up
over the general population they want
more benefits they want they feel like
they've they've been entitled to it like
I heard somebody say on like my Twitter
the other day like this Flag represents
uh all the people who died to sacrifice
so that we could fly I'm like who died
like who was out there dyingly we would
have known we would have known their
name just like George Floyd right we
would have known every detail about them
that they actually died for the LGBT
flag stop right but but the masses they
are sick and indoctrinated and they
believe this stuff this isn't just
activists this is like crazy people
talking to each other with a
reinforcement mechanism going over and
over and over again I used to think that
it was like puppets it's not it's people
like saying oh I want it easy too or I
want some benefit of being some victim
and they they live in some Echo chamber
that keeps growing because there's
obviously benefits about being a victim
and so that's what's happening like it's
not it's not like these activists
pulling strengths they're just
capitalizing off of The psychosis of the
masses but I think the it's it's it's
about the the critical mass in this
country
most people didn't care and refused to
engage so what happens anybody who wants
to run amok runs amok yep these big
corporations yes ESG plays a role and
I've been saying this for a while it's
not just that it's that they think it
makes sense it makes money for them so
let's consider this for Starbucks how
does it come to the point where they're
like take this stuff down simple there's
probably a marketing meeting where they
were like what's going on with this Bud
Light thing this is kind of worrying and
they said yeah there's a lot of people
who are angry over the pride stuff and
so they're boycotting Bud Light sales
are down 30 Target sales are down
targets market cap and anheuser's market
cap are going down these other companies
are seeing it too and then Starbucks
some some executive goes okay well are
we doing this they said yes we do have a
pride month display and they go okay why
they're like well I mean it was a the
popular thing to do I mean everybody did
was just participating and this and he
probably said okay how much money do we
stand to make by marketing to this group
of people and they were like well to be
honest the average person is going to
shop at Starbucks and matter what if we
if we do or don't celebrate this and
they went okay well how much money do we
lose if we put these flags up well Bud
Light took a 30 hit take them down
there's no benefit anymore when no one
cared there was no risk and they said eh
maybe we'll bump our sales by four
percent now that the risk is 30 plus
percent they're saying there's no reward
but they also in they also open
themselves up to Legal liability too you
have a fiduciary responsibility to your
shareholders and if you're doing things
that you know will purposely drive down
your stock you're liable right yeah so
it's their job to make money for their
shareholders if they see this stuff
going on with Bud Light and Target they
have a responsibility to stop it because
if not they're not protecting their
shareholders well and I think one thing
a lot of these organizations a lot of
these companies are going to start to
realize if they haven't already it's
that the people who they might offend in
terms of their customer base the people
who they might drive away
are people who are already shopping
there in violation of their principles
right so if you're somebody who's uh on
the far left to the point where you buy
into this gender ideology there's a
pretty strong overlap between you and
people who say things like there's no
ethical consumption under capitalism or
I hate big corporations and I think that
the means of production need to be
equitably distributed across everyone
who works within a particular sector
right so my point is people who are on
the far left who are patronizing
Corporate America are already purchasing
in violation of their principles so if
they get offended by you not celebrating
pride month the chances that they're
going to
suddenly decide to inconvenience
themselves in the name of their
principles is very low because they've
never done it before there's there's a
really strong overlap for some reason
between socialists
Communists and support for massive
multinational capitalist corporations
yeah they're using them to actually mash
up the American Republic or attempt to
smash up their American Republic I think
they're just Hypocrites who have no idea
what they're talking about and it's more
like a chaotic and destructive force
with no with no real plans or aims just
the exertion of power whatever's anti
what I want destroyed that's the
mentality yeah I think uh what something
you might be missing or I think uh I
think Trump is coming out not Ian you
can't tell me why I'm wrong Trump's here
Trump is Trump is now stepping up
ex-president I gotcha I was gonna make a
good point too he's got times waiting
for me
uh
not saying not all gay people are coming
it's basically what I'm going to say oh
yeah no no I'm gonna do it of course not
we have Donald Trump stepping up to the
podium
[Applause]
look at that tan
[Music]
look at all those phones you can see
Trump in various angles look at this one
I feel so bad for him for trump
it hurts my heart looking at him
well it's his biggest crime about to
help America and they're torturing them
they're killing them
disgusting
come on DJ Trump oh my gosh
I gotta make that you have to catch the
hook in it I'm proud to be America and
I'm proud
[Music]
he's a half an hour late but he's still
just standing there
jamming out if I go to the bathroom you
think he'll still be standing there when
I get there no here we go the music
coming down
he's gonna make so much money tonight I
already got two texts I I should read
them oh for fundraisers did I get any
this is oh yeah
never mind Lisa during these dark hours
I hope my message reminds you that we
are unbreakable watch and so then
there's a video and then the Thundering
I think all right Trump I love you but I
gotta go to the bathroom man I'll see
you in a minute he's just standing there
waiting watching you will leave the song
play waiting for you to come back
what if Trump goes into the microphone
and goes I'll begin talking in just a
minute but Ian's gotta come back we're
waiting for Ian to wait it's free
people are gonna be like what you need
to get him on I think you could do it
yeah they just we have to go to him so
what go I know right so we've been like
talking with uh many of the people in
the Trump camp and they're just like you
gotta all right
here we go
[Applause]
thank you it's great honor to have you
here and
today we witnessed the most evil and
heinous abuse of power in the history of
our country very sad thing to watch a
corrupt sitting president had his top
political opponent arrested on fake and
fabricated charges of which he and
numerous other presidents would be
guilty
right in the middle of a presidential
election
in which he was losing very badly
I'm gonna try this other audio an
interference and yet another attempt to
rig and steal it just got better
elect more importantly it's safe there
we go was that us political persecution
like something straight out of a fascist
or a communist Nation
this day will go down and infamy and Joe
Biden will forever be remembered as not
only the most corrupt president of the
history of our country but perhaps even
more importantly
the president who together with a band
of his closest thugs Misfits and
marxists tried to destroy American
democracy
but they will fail and we will win
bigger and better than ever before
charging a former president of the
United States under the Espionage Act of
1917 wasn't meant for this
an act for a crime so heinous that only
the death penalty would do and
threatening me with 400 years in prison
wow for possessing my own presidential
papers which just about every other
president has done is one of the most
outrageous and vicious legal theories
ever put forward in an American court of
law
the Espionage Act
has been used to go after Traders and
spies it has nothing to do with a former
president legally keeping his own
documents
as president the law that applies to
this case is not
the Espionage Act but very simply the
presidential records Act
which is not even mentioned in this
ridiculous 44-page indictment
under the presidential records act which
is civil not Criminal
I had every right to have these
documents
The crucial legal precedent is laid out
in the most important case ever on the
subject known as the Clinton Sox case
you know what that means
after leaving the White House Bill
Clinton kept 79 audiotapes
in his sock draw
they included discussions of U.S
military involvement in Haiti
discussions of U.S foreign policy both
defense and offense against Cuba
recordings of President Clinton's
conversations with
all of the many foreign leaders at the
time think of that sensitive facts about
trade negotiations taken from
presidential briefings discussions with
the Secretary of State about conflict in
Bosnia and much much more
very big stuff Not only was Bill Clinton
never even considered for criminal
prosecution based on the tapes he took
but when he was sued for them he won the
case
Judge Amy Berman Jackson's decision
States under the statutory scheme
established by the presidential records
Act
the decision to segregate personal
materials from presidential records is
made by the president during the
president's term
and in the president's
Soul discretion
you're surprised to hear that aren't you
any normal Administration even an
opposing one would consider that to be
the end
but not the corrupt Biden Administration
the Sox decision as it's known
also States quote the National Archives
and Records Administration or Nara
does not have the authority to designate
material as presidential records I don't
have the authority
Nara does not have the tapes in question
and narrow lacks any right Duty or means
to seize control of them this is law
the president enjoys unconstrained
authority to make decisions regarding
the disposal of documents that's
unconstrained
to make that decision neither the
archivist nor Congress has the authority
to veto the president's decision
the presidential records act does not
confer any mandatory or even
discretionary Authority or the archivist
to classify records
under the statute this responsibility is
left solely
to the president of the United States
think of that that's the decision think
of that
now just think of that in other words
whatever documents the president decides
to take with him he has the right to do
so it's an absolute right this is the
law
and that is something that people have
now seen and it couldn't be more clear
they ought to drop this case immediately
because they're destroying the country
and this is why no other president even
those who kept far more documents than I
has ever
been even investigated let alone charged
with a crime
because the Sham indictment put forward
by the Biden Administration included
stage photographs of boxes at Mar-A-Lago
many people have asked me why
I had these boxes why did you want them
the answer in addition to having every
right under the presidential records Act
is that these boxes were
containing all types of personal
belongings many many things shirts and
shoes and everything
as can be seen in the picture where
someone not me
I wonder who it might have been
dumped one of the very neatly arranged
boxes all over the floor
they were full of newspapers press
clippings thousands of pictures
thousands and thousands of White House
pictures
the White House photographers some are
with us today they took so many pictures
and we saved all of them and they were
in those boxes
clothing memorabilia and much much more
I hadn't had a chance to go through all
the boxes it's a long tedious job takes
a long time
which I was prepared to do but I have a
very busy life I've had a very busy life
they make it more busy because you're
always fighting
and under the Sox decision
there seemed to be no rush I wasn't in a
rush because that decision was a law
the other picture that was so vile you
remember that one it was angry and
corrupt was the photo staged by the FBI
and those that raided Mar-A-Lago they
were putting documents all over the
floor remember that famous picture all
over say confidential said presidentials
and all sorts of things and it was
supposed to be there like
it was that way when they raided it
wasn't that way they put them there took
the picture and released it illegally to
the Press
they took my medical records my passport
my birth certificate and apologized
they even brought a safe tractor and
this is a professional safe cracker they
brought into Mar-A-Lago
and they broke into my safe and you know
what they found nothing there was
nothing there
zero
according to the presidential records
act which was a big deal
I was supposed to negotiate with Nara
which is exactly what I was doing until
Mar-A-Lago was raided by gun toting FBI
agents
I have security tapes of it I gave them
security tapes of everything
in a flagrant violation of the Fourth
Amendment of the Constitution which
protects the right against
unreasonable search
and seizure
and Sebastian you covered very well I
must say
very well I'm not the one who thinks I'm
above the law I'm the one that followed
the law I'm the only one
it's Joe Biden and his corrupt depart
Department of Injustice who think they
are above the law
never before have the two standards of
Justice in our country been more starkly
revealed
Joe Biden had troves of classified
documents from his time as vice
president and even as a senator
which was completely and totally illegal
in fact other Senators heard about it
Dick Durbin heard about it you have to
see his response there's no way that's
totally illegal took him as a senator
out of a skiff
they were shocked when they found out
they actually thought it was impossible
to do
Biden sent
1850 boxes to the University of Delaware
making the search very very difficult
for anybody
and he refuses to give them up and he
refuses to let people even look at them
and then they say how he's behaving so
nicely
many of Biden's classified documents
were in Chinatown DC Chinatown
which is shocking considering his family
receives so much money from China I
wonder how many times the
friends of ours from China review those
documents Chinatown DC
others were unsecured at his so-called
Penn Biden Center in Washington which
paid Biden approximately one million
dollars a year the money supposedly
coming from China and still other
classified documents with strewn
all over his garage floor where his now
famous Corvette is stored he's so proud
of that car
there was no security and the door was
left open
most of the time it was open all of
those classified documents all of those
documents strewn all over the floor
piled up like junk
unlike me who had absolute
declassification Authority as president
Joe Biden as vice president had no
authority to declassify and no right to
possess
the documents he had no right instead of
falling under the presidential records
act Biden's actions fell under a much
stricter Federal records act which has
very very tough
criminal penalties yet nothing happens
to Crooked Joe nothing happened have you
heard anything about the big search for
his documents no only me
most and famously of all Hillary Clinton
set up an illegal private server in her
basement you never heard this story with
a deliberate intention of violating
public information laws so she could
hide her pay for play scandals at the
Clinton foundations or whatever
Hillary stored vast quantities of
classified and sensitive information on
her illicit server
some of it happened to Lake it leaked
into Anthony Weiner's computer remember
Anthony Weiner
into his computer you don't want to be
on his computer
it was illegal because thankfully she
was never president she didn't have the
powers to declassify this is true
and her staff smashed phones with
hammers she didn't have the powers to
declassify it's a big difference and
neither did Joe you know Joe didn't have
your mind have a drink the fact that
hers was electronic made it worse
because it was it's a little bit
yep thank you happy birthday happy
birthday great birthday
for this month
he's gonna DJ nice birthday isn't it 65
degrees in Bedminster
[Applause]
no but yeah
we should have cake
wonderful birthday
hours with Eric and Laura the kids happy
birthday grandpa happy and I say oh
great I just got charged with they won
400 years
if you add them all up a fake
a fake 400 years ago thank you darling
that's so nice
to the greatest birthday of all we'll
make it into the greatest
when caught Hillary then deleted
and acid washed Nobody Does that because
of the expense but it's pretty
conclusive 33
000 emails in defiance of a
congressional subpoena already launched
the subpoena was there and she decided
to delete acid wash and then Smash and
Destroy her cell phones with a hammer
and then this is their staff that did it
participated in obstruction
now think of it that's called
obstruction
there's never been obstruction as Grave
as that she did this in the face of
everything and yet
nobody did anything about it
the FBI and the doj protected her did
not issue subpoenas did not use a grand
jury did not execute search warrants and
then the
corrupt head of the FBI James Comey
declared no reasonable prosecutor would
bring a case can you believe it
[Music]
[Applause]
and there was just one of many items
Hillary Clinton broke the law
and she didn't get indicted
Joe Biden broke the law and in many
other ways we're finding out
and so far has not gotten indicted I did
everything right and they indicted me
but you know we're serving as a great
example and
the case of Bill Clinton's National
Security adviser remember that Sandy
Berger he was caught stealing classified
documents from the National Archives
very big ones very important ones by
stuffing them in his pants that's pretty
and putting them also in his socks and
he destroyed them and cut
the tape with scissors cut them all up
what Burger did was highly illegal but
he was given
nothing no jail time nothing nothing
happened there are countless other
examples Bill Clinton
who I happen to like hard to believe
right before I did this I was actually
quite friendly with him
nice guy they should have used him a
little bit more as an advisor on the
2016 election he said you know you
better get to Wisconsin you're going to
lose no we're not you better get to
Michigan you're going to lose Noah not
they did
Bill Clinton lost the nuclear codes and
absolutely nothing was done about he'd
lost the nuclear codes
the George W bush White House lost
22 million emails a record
Nara cannot issue a complete transfer of
any of the Bush records
a document shredding truck was spotted
on the way to
Dick Cheney's house can you imagine
Hillary Clinton took hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of furniture
China flatware rugs and more from the
White House
and she wasn't prosecuted how about that
when she took the furniture
and the China
How about if Trump did that do you think
Trump would have a little problem
the horrific violations of my rights by
crooked Joe Biden's weaponized
Department of Injustice are Unthinkable
it's Unthinkable what's happened so bad
for our country
Democrats all
they lawlessly pierced
my attorney-client privilege with
lawyers what they did to lawyers what
they have done to our lawyers our
lawyers all of our lawyers they've done
things that were absolutely horrible and
unthinkable
the leaking has been unbelievable and
highly illegal they leak
we've learned more about
from The Washington Post New York Times
about the doj's boxes hoax it's a boxes
hoax
than from prosecutors themselves we want
to read about it you pick up the
Washington Post
which is not doing well will you pick up
the New York Times but they'll do better
now because of these things you know
this is the only way they survive but
they'll end up dying
but it's not supposed to be that way we
don't want to learn from the times we
don't want to learn from leaks we want
to learn from the people we're supposed
to learn from it's like a leaking sieve
in Washington
but we learned nothing about the Biden
bribery scheme or special counsel Robert
Herr's investigation Robert Herr is
doing the Biden investigation he's a
very respected very nice person
very nice person
mine's not such a nice person mine's a
deranged lunatic
which are many times the magnitude of
ours in both number and severity
that's the prosecutor that they gave he
has found nothing he totally exonerated
Mike Pence I'm happy about that Mike did
nothing wrong but he happened to have
classified documents in his house
but they exonerated him and Biden is a
different story I mean so much you have
to really think about what I said as a
senator he took all of those documents
it's unprecedented
the prosecutor in the case
I will call it our case is a thug I've
named him deranged Jack Smith
I've named I wonder what his name used
to be Jack Smith it sounds so innocent
Dustin Jack Smith what's his name Jack
Smith he's a very nice man he's a behind
the scenes guy
but his record is absolutely atrocious
he does political hit jobs he's
been known to viciously arrest a certain
Governor you know the governor
Bob McDonald of Virginia and absolutely
ruined his life and the life of his
family all these wonderful family
members I knew them
only to have the case overturned eight
to nothing by the Supreme Court he
destroyed that man and he destroyed that
family
and by the way
I will tell you I'm here and I love you
all
and we can take it
[Applause]
seems in my family is a disgrace I will
tell you that I say it to all of the
fake news this is a lot of impact
[Music]
what they did to my family and that
young man right there
he's answered more subpoenas than any
human being in the history of the world
and you know what they have nothing
after all of those subpoenas it's
literally thousands of them
Congress
fake councils Mueller report all of this
all he did is answer subpoenas all the
time at least he's become very
experienced at that congratulations
But Eric is fantastic and what he and
Don Ivanka and the whole group that's
what they've gone through and these are
serious people
these are serious people but what he's
done to my family what they have done to
my family is horrible he also tried to
Railroad John Edwards on a completely
bogus legal theory that didn't hold up
in court
it's no wonder this raging lunatic was
shipped off to the Hague to prosecute
war criminals using globalist tribunals
not beholden to the Constitution or the
rule of law two things Jack Smith
clearly disdains you take a look at this
guy he looks like a thug
but then I watched him make a speech the
other day and he was trembling because
it wasn't his territory he feels much
safer
in the inner sanctums of the Department
of Injustice where he can be in his room
and scream at people
he's a raging and uncontrolled Trump
hater
as is his wife who also happened to be
the producer of that Michelle Obama puff
pieces total puff piece
this is the guy I've got
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people much as if
they were trying to destabilize wow a
foreign country from the russia-russia
Russia hopes to the no collusion Mueller
Witch Hunt
to impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the 51 lying
intelligence offers how about them
they said it's Russia disinformation and
they knew it wasn't which made about
According to some of the great pollsters
that are right here made from anywhere
from a 10 to 17 point difference and yet
we still got more votes than any sitting
president in history in the second
election he deserves to get out of jail
free card for the whole world seriously
the fake dossier paid for by the
Democrats how about the fake dossier
remember that one you think that was
easy to go home and say Hello darling
how are you when they read about that
wasn't easy at all
spying on my campaign we caught them
spying on my campaign the FBI Twitter
files and so much more
it's all been a battle of disinformation
one thing after the other
and all to protect the radical left
Misfits
it's also no coincidence that these
charges against me came down the very
same day
evidence revealed Joe Biden took a 5
million dollar bribe from Ukraine took a
five million dollar abroad
but the FBI and the justice department
don't even want to talk about I think
Joe and Hunter both something on
television tonight it had seven time on
the three major networks
allegedly I think I had 351 minutes they
had no minutes
okay
I think a lot of people are going to
vote yeah I think a lot of people
I will tell you I just left Miami and
I've never seen love in the streets like
that I've never seen it we've seen a lot
of love
I've never seen love like that because
they know they know what we all go
through they know what we've gone
through and they see it and they're
smart and you know many of those people
coming from Cuba Venezuela other
countries they've seen this happening to
their countries I used to say that the
United States if it keeps going this way
it's going to be Venezuela on steroids
and now we're buying oil from Venezuela
can you believe we have more Liquid Gold
under our feet than any other Nation but
we're buying tar
from Venezuela and we're refining it in
Houston the dirtiest worst oil probably
anywhere in the world
and we're refining it so you can imagine
what's going up in the air and all
beautiful stuff we're not taken out of
the ground and making a lot of money and
paying off debt and reducing taxes still
further which we were in the process of
doing
they want to distract from the real
Espionage and the real crime so let's
use president Trump to do so let's go
out and let's indict president Trump so
they don't talk about the five million
dollar bribe just yesterday Senator
Grassley revealed that the barisma
executive who allegedly paid the bribe
reportedly has crooked Joe
on tape they have 17 tapes I understand
that he must be a nice guy to deal with
right
the guy from barisma nice company
they got him in Hunter on 17 different
types supposedly but the FBI isn't
showing them
remember they impeached me for asking a
simple question about Biden's corrupt
dealings in Ukraine and now they see
that once again I was right I was right
I was totally right yep
allegedly
Joe Biden and the radical left can take
foreign bribes and be totally protected
Republicans all you must finally get
tough you've got to get tough you've got
to get tough and you got to show them
when you arrest your leading police
they're going to call that incitement or
something or have a democracy when
people are allowed to pour through our
open borders our elections are rigged
our country is in very serious trouble
when inflation is allowed to rage when
energy Independence and dominance it's
we had Independence and dominance we
were going to be soon very very dominant
within six months we're going to
dominate the whole world with energy
make a fortune we were going to be
paying off debt and lowering taxes at a
level that nobody's ever seen and they
came in and they ended it
but when that's taken away from us when
interest rates and taxes spiral upward
in an uncontrolled way
when murders are allowed to Rome
murderers these are horrible Killers
murderers are allowed to roam the
streets of our democrat-run cities
unchecked
but the incompetent district attorney in
New York indicts Trump for a crime that
everybody agrees every pundit everybody
there is no crime
but murderers go out and nobody ever
even comes and knocks on their door and
they know they're there and they know
their rooms and they know their
locations and they're roaming our cities
all over and some of them are coming in
right now through our borders
but then you have a nation that as we
are is in serious serious decline we
have a nation in Syria state line
if the Communists get away with this
it won't stop with me they will not
hesitate to ramp up their persecution of
Christians pro-life activists parents
attending school board meetings and even
future Republican candidates which they
do
we must end it permanently and we must
end it immediately now that the seal
good for him so important is broken the
seal is broken by what they've done they
should never have done this
this was an Unwritten rule you just
don't
unless it's really bad but you just
don't but the seal is now broken
in addition to closing the border and
removing all of the criminal elements
that have illegally invaded our country
make it America energy independent and
even dominant again and immediately
ending the war between Russia and
Ukraine I'll have it ended in 24 hours I
think it'll be faster than that me too I
think I'll be the war will stop before
he even assumes the point a real special
prosecutor to go after the most corrupt
president of the history of the United
States of America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
he is he really he really still has and
all others
and our country itself they're
destroying our country
and when I'm re-elected and we will get
reelected we have no choice we're not
going to have a country anymore I will
totally obliterate the Deep State yeah
this is what I want the Trump revenge
tour nobody else can do it I don't care
I want you to go in there and get ready
I want to see look at this look at this
morning PBS point
ah
silence you they want to experience that
makes me mad that's exciting all right
I just happen to be standing in their
way and I will never be moving
[Applause]
get rid of every single person in there
that's even looked at his name yeah so
this is this is the PBS feed and uh at
the end it said violent political
rhetoric has escalated among right-wing
militias and online forums as he's
saying I'm gonna fire these people dude
it started with and it's calling context
it said context inflammatory rhetoric
can cause people to give an acts of
violence or influences people who can
acts of violence I mean unbelievable you
could almost argue that that statement
by PBS was an inflammation of acts of
violence
saying the things that you're seeing
right now might cause you to become like
that's like yeah almost like inside
there's there's there's nobody else
there's there's nobody else so that's
the unfortunate thing because I don't
think it's his whole I'm gonna go in
there and end everything is the right
way to create a new better world really
are that actually surprises me that's
your position if I burned it all down
we'd all die in a horrible fire like
what's the value
come on come on saying we want to weed
out corruption it's not the same as
destroy this yeah but he's like I'm
gonna go fire I'm gonna go obliterate
the Deep state is the most vague uh
nonsensical statement like what does he
mean he's going to issue pink slips and
they're just gonna say okay no schedule
F as as he already implemented in his
first term and then did not win
re-election so was not able to carry out
and then Biden I think was I think was
the bite admission that reversed it was
the
basically he was setting the policy for
we are going to fire people who have
been permanently in government and who
should not be here anymore the idea that
you can get hired by the federal
government be bad at your job be corrupt
and not get fired is insane so when he
implements schedule F he then says if I
get reelected we're going to bring back
schedule F and start firing these
corrupt individuals why would your
position be that's bad because he's
talking about people that just got hired
six weeks ago he's going to fire them
but he's but but he's literally
all of them that would be complete
Insanity he'd disband the federal
government like what why isn't said
that's what they did to the Iraqis after
the Gulf War and it created uh they are
targeting us Ian they are targeting you
you are but hold on hold on hold on
going from there are permanent
bureaucrats who should be fired to your
statement Ian he's going to shut down
the whole government that's not what
that no the Deep state is the same kind
of uh tautology that got Kennedy killed
I I believe tautology is the right word
I'm going to look up the definition you
can't I mean if you just say it's
everything and they're all like yeah
tautology is like Love Is Love right
it's when you just like exactly
when Donald Trump
When Donald Trump spends years and and
other uh advisors and individuals in his
Circle spend years describing what is
called as the permanent government
individuals who work in the federal
government who have been there
throughout multiple administrations who
set policy and need to be fired for
wrongdoing that's what he has explained
over and over again and then he says
we've got to fire these people
colloquially they're called The Deep
state
so I think you just didn't know about
heads of agencies are you talking about
every employee what do you mean there
are people who have been some some are
uh in charge some were even uh he
mistakenly hired some you know he made
he made big mistakes in that regard but
we're not talking about going to the
entirety of a single agency and
literally just firing every single
person and then leaving an empty room
he's saying there are people who need to
be fired who can't be fired but he's
like imagine if you bought a pizza
restaurant and everybody in there was
sitting around and nobody was working
and you're like why am I paying you
people like Union contract you can't
fire us and so then some guy's like okay
well I'm gonna buy this pizza place and
then I'm sending a new policy I'm gonna
negotiate a new contract and say I can
fire if you don't do your job so then
the people who work there all team up
conspire accuse you of crimes and have
you arrested
Ian have you ever lived through a
government shutdown yes because you have
because you're yeah
no no no like a government shutdown at
the end of the year when when they don't
meet the Appropriations bills right and
they only have essential people working
right from the federal government you
don't notice it you don't feel it at all
a day in your life they could cut all of
those people if you are non-essential if
you're a non-essential worker and you
get laid off during a government
shutdown I'm sorry goodbye but that's
that's a that's a fiscal argument that's
like we're wasting so much money on
people well I I I'm just saying you're
right on top of that I mean like you're
not going to feel it all if all of these
leeches and these corrupt people the
people that are not implementing the
president's policy because they don't
like him
are are still in power or because that's
what they are I mean if he if he puts
out a policy and they say we're going to
slow walk this we're not going to
implement it then then they do actually
have power they're not elected they need
to go they need to go all of them need
to go
well I'm open to that but having a
president do it with the authoritarian
Zeal is like wait wait yo legislate that
let Congress do that why but but they're
going after they're different branches
of government no no no stop stop it's a
different branch of governments Congress
is one branch there is the judicial
branch and there's the executive branch
Donald Trump would be the head of the
executive branch Congress is not going
to go and fire staff for which they are
not involved a different branch of
government the separation of powers
exist for a reason well are you so that
we don't have dictators but going and
destroying branches if I was gonna your
pizza shop metaphors
his branch of government and saying bad
people should be fired is exactly he
said I'm going to obliterate the Deep
State and that means he's gonna in the
executive nullify the FBI there will be
no FBI effect that's the executive
branch are you saying fire that people
that work there that hire new people Ian
what do you say you are being willfully
obtused what do you think the Deep state
is just out of curiosity like how would
you define the Deep State because I feel
like that's where we're all a little did
bureaucratic officials with nefarious
intentions no no I don't know what
they're okay see this is where you are
making things up and if you don't
understand what is being said you can
answer the question I'm not making it
that's not how I Define the Deep State
officials how would you define it so the
permanent government so we can go back
to the hearings that actually took place
when they had NSA officials and they
discussed does the Deep says exist and
they said no it doesn't and people in
the media ran articles saying there is
no deep State they then said we call it
the permanent government these are
certain elements within certain
departments who have been here
throughout multiple administrations and
set policies they are unelected in many
instances some of these people have
committed overt violations of either a
law like the Hatch Act for instance
which seems to get violated a lot or
just in general they did things that
weren't firing
so when when for years we're having a
discussion about people who for some
reason can't be fired and should be
fired and then Donald Trump comes along
and says that guy needs to be fired we
go yeah he's right you then say no the
Deep State means something totally
different than my assume give me names
Don if you're gonna fire people tell me
who you're gonna fire I don't want to
hear that you're gonna obliterate the
government that doesn't happen
obliterate the Deep State it's
obliterate the FBI the CIA the NSA like
send them to there is none anymore
that's what that term you're
obliterating the the people that are
obstructionary in there from
implementing his policy the people that
have been unelected that have been
targeting him that have been targeting
conservatives like in the IRS right when
you can't when they're targeting
churches and and conservative 501c3's
just because they have the name Patriot
in it those people are the deep deep
State that's who they are they are the
obstructive people who hate us they hate
you for not even paying like for not
following their line they don't like us
I think that's a dirty tactics you tell
people that they're hated by other
people you don't know and you're gonna
think I know them they don't know me
you're an authoritarian you have hard
authoritarian Tendencies let me ask you
a question when Donald Trump tried to
pull all of our troops out of Syria was
that a good thing
uh at face value yeah that war was
ridiculous and it wasn't a war was it
was it good when there was a uh uh
officials who lied to Donald Trump to
keep troops in Syria no man but these
are these are real pointers
what was going on I don't know if it
would have killed a bunch of people if
they'd pulled out I don't know what the
situation was there right but it's
Advanced value if the president issues
an order and it's violated there's a big
problem in the chain of command that
person should be reprimanded should they
be fired for lying to the president and
the American people to keep military
activity ongoing in a country we did not
declare potentially yeah if you're a
commander and one of your dudes goes out
and to violate one of your orders you
may not fire him because there may be
some you know rudimentary justification
there was there was a while ago I
referred to you as the banality of evil
and this is a really good example of
that see for in my world and I wonder if
you guys agree with me and the people
listening agree if there is a
commander-in-chief who has been duly
elected by the people of his of his
country
to properly lead and serve out his term
as the commander-in-chief of the Armed
Forces and he says
I order my troops to be removed and then
tells the American people we are getting
our troops out of Syria and then an
official behind the backs of the
American people lies to the president to
keep troops on the ground in a foreign
country we did not declare war on that
person is a traitor to this country that
person is committing seditious
conspiracy amen and is actively engaged
in a foreign I mean the amount of laws
that were violated it is it's not even a
question and this is fact we know that
happened there is so when I say the
banality of evil what you are saying is
you know what I just don't know let the
evil people keep doing their thing and
I'm like bro we can outright see there's
a guy who is obstructing the will of the
people that and the duly elected
president to serve out his term and end
a foreign war we did not want and you're
like I don't know we might want to keep
him give me the guy's name no no let's
put it this way the executive branch
serves at the pleasure of the president
that is what it actually says they serve
at the pleasure of the president so now
they're his staff these executive branch
and the people that work there are his
death would you would you come and like
keep a whole bunch of people who maybe I
would say eighty percent you're are
known to be uh to object to your
policies would you just clean house and
hire your own staff right and kill that
deep State that's been there for years
would you know that wouldn't you want to
know them wouldn't you want to know that
they were on your side and he has every
right to do that it's like if if you
were to buy have your own company Tim
wouldn't buy a media company even though
it was all lefties and say yeah you can
all still work here here you go
task and purpose newsguard certified 100
out of 100 top U.S official admits lying
to Trump on American troop levels in
Syria saying we were always playing
Shell Games to not make clear to our
leadership how many trips we had there
it's insane treason yep what happened to
this guy nothing nothing ever and this
is exactly what we're talking about this
guy should be criminally charged yeah
you are being exact this is we should be
exact if we're talking about firing
people in the federal government Donald
Trump is not going to stand up with a
half an hour's time and say uh I'd like
to give you a list of every single
person needs to be fired here we go
starting in alphabetical order that's
insane well the reason so when when we
have this conversation and then Trump
addresses it and then a week later we
have another conversation but another
corrupt official and we have a
conversation Who's Who uh who's the guy
who lied before Congress about spying on
the American people uh James Clapper did
hey he should be in jail he should have
been so charged when when that when that
story happens
we go hey that's that guy's bad
and then Trump says I agree we should
arrest these people then we have another
story here this guy he's bad we should
arrest that guy yeah he committed a
crime then with a half an hour standing
at a Podium Trump's got a short amount
of time to explain his plans he says
we're going to go after these people
we're going to obliterate the Deep State
he's talking about this I hope what do
you mean you hope it's literally what
he's been talking about
he's gonna go after who are you worried
for in the Deep State
specifically refers to the corrupt
individuals like I don't think
corruption it's just it really does no
so so why is it why is it that we get
swatted 15 times and there's no action
taken none wait where the multiple
agencies to deal with the fact that
across Federal now I wonder but why did
so many FBI agents go and investigate a
garage pull rope for no reason for no
reason see the issue is the Deep State
isn't every single FBI uh agent the Deep
state is many of them in fact depending
on who you want to ask you go back to
Hoover the Deep state may just be
literally the whole agency but there are
a lot of people in the FBI who have
actually done things that go after child
exploitation we've seen that I like that
stuff Stop Those Predators but you know
what the problem is right now you have
uh I don't know uh we get swatted 15
times nothing garage pull up
investigated Donald Trump criminally
charged Hillary Clinton not criminally
charged Joe Biden not criminally charged
this is the Deep state
and I have actually talked to people who
work in the intelligence agencies
uh and I've asked them what's it like is
it really that bad you know they say to
me they said it's exactly the same on
the inside as it is in the on the
outside a lot of good people who are too
scared to speak up because their bosses
are woke and they're scared they're
going to get fired or something bad is
going to happen and I'm like this is the
problem you've got core elements of
corrupt individuals who are deranged
cultists who are like we must imprison
Trump no matter what lying about what
Trump has done pushing these lies
relentlessly and refusing to criminally
charge anybody else hey you don't want
to arrest Hillary Clinton fine how can
you then turn around and go after Trump
for something that's not even as bad as
smashing phones with hammers and using
bleach bit a software to purge the hard
drive so no data could ever be recovered
a a clear violation of public records
law and so Donald Trump says we got to
get rid of this corruption and that's it
plain and simple I don't believe Ronda
Sanders will do it I just don't either I
think I think he's got great the Paul's
gonna do it man he said he was going to
drain the swamp like he told me two
years when he's running for president
when he had another coming up this would
be his last opportunity to run for
president and he has been so wronged and
so violated in the meantime since
January 6 basically that he would go
scorched Earth and he would drain the
swamp that's why I wanna we don't live
our lives down Paths of absolute
certainty
we walk towards we we are walking down a
road and we come across a variety of
paths before us and we try and look into
the distance down each path to figure
out which one is the safe route to our
right we see thunder lightning and scary
trees and crows and we go oh that looks
scary to our left we see sunshine and
rainbows we do not know what actual is
the end of those paths but we can take
our best guess I'm gonna go with the
sunshine and rainbows over the dark and
scary Forest now it may turn out once
you get to the end of that Sunshine all
of a sudden there's big cloud-shaped
monsters that attack you and if you go
through the the crazy Forest there's a
bunch of wood elves having a delicious
feast and you know it made the wrong
choice the best thing we can do is say
what is our best likelihood at solving
the problem of corruption in this
country and it is Donald Trump does that
mean we have a guarantee he'll do it
absolutely not in fact he'll probably
screw up a lot but if that chance is 51
and any other candidate is 10 I go with
51 if he's the only one who's standing
up saying we will fire them then is the
only one worthy of voting for vivek's
doing a little bit of that yes
absolutely I want to mention this so is
my mom we're we're also I just want to
acknowledge this we've all sort of
mentioned some of our disappointments
with Trump's presidency the fact that he
said he was going to drain the swamp and
didn't he didn't get rid of all of these
people but similarly you know right you
can argue that drain the swamp is also
as vague as obliterate the Deep state
but we know there are certain agencies
that are filled with corrupt people who
need to be taken out I would argue that
especially after
facing 400 years in prison on these
quite literally trumped-up charges he's
going to be more motivated than ever
before to really go after these people
it's it's very challenging for me to
talk about this from the outside because
I don't know what he knows and if he
knows all the specific people that he
needs to fire to set off the chain of
action to actually create a more just
system I can get behind that but if he's
just like angry and and like doesn't
know who he's gonna go after and he's
just saying this then it strikes me as a
platitude stuff that Hitler would I've
been concerned about Hitler I've been
listening to these Nazi speeches of
Hitler being like
these are evil Bad the news is bad vile
these get these evil people For the Love
of All that is good in our country and
then they're all cheering with for love
and it's like dude he spent 95 of his
speech talking about hate and then at
the very end he's like love love love
platitude and everyone feels gets this
endorphin rush and like it's it better
be more than an endorphin so this is
this is this is what the media does to
people they scream over and over again
that Trump is Hitler they find whatever
dubious parallels they can and they try
and convince you that you're looking at
you're looking in in a reflection which
you are completely and absolutely not
it's just it's just not it's it's
ridiculous these people come out and
they're like you know you're a fascist
and it's like yo I believe in civil
liberties Free Speech civil
libertarianism I want the government to
be smaller and they're like you're a
fascist you know what it is
see the people who want absolute
Authority the violent fervor is not on
the right
how is it that Sheamus and I can
disagree on you know big political
issues and debates even around
spirituality uh obvious issues like
abortion yet here we are every day
laughing together having conversations
trying to live and work together this
side is not the fervent zealous side the
people who claim to be leftists but
cheer for every massive multinational
corporation and government mandate those
are the fascists it's a lot of drug
addicts but yeah Hassan piker's not not
a drug addict well I don't know if
Pharmaceuticals he's using a lot of
people that are addicted to like Ritalin
and stuff like that my point is I have
the emotional using Hassan as a good
example I find it fascinating that he
ends up on the side of massive
multinational corporations so often he
criticized Nick marks because Nick marks
didn't want to didn't support vaccine
mandates and I'm like how was the
Socialist guy in favor of literally
massive multinational Pharmaceuticals
having no bid no liability contracts
contracts where the people are mandated
to take a drug that's that's that's like
if you want to talk about nightmare
dystopia books how about one where the
government forces people to take drugs
and if you find yourself on that side
you're a fascist now I know quite
literally I'm going to get every Lefty
in the world messaging me now being like
two molecular so shut up you can't you
can't sit here and be like damn Paul's a
fascist Because he believes that Frisk
and then go around mandating and
demanding the government force people to
be medicated y'all are Fascist I don't
care what you want to say you're
authoritarian crackpots there's no
guarantee voting for Trump saves
anything there's no guarantee that Ron
DeSantis there's certainly I I would say
I guarantee that if you vote for Joe
Biden it will get worse correct so I can
only say this I'm looking at the board
and I'm like where am I going to put my
chips Donald Trump yeah and that speech
there's a lot to talk about in that
speech and I kind of hijacked it talking
about this the other thing that set me
off is the way that the Americans got
rid of the bath party in Iraq after the
after the invasion in 2004 caused a
political a gap like a vacancy in the
government and then the Isis comes in
and starts taking control and forming so
I I was concerned about that with
eradicating the Deep State firing all
this leadership that a new Not only
would all those fired people go off and
start their own Rogue government or
structure that then there would be but
particularly that that the
disenfranchised ex-employment you seem
to be very worried about a totalitarian
government right but at this point I
think and it's going to sound well a
trumpian authoritarian government is so
much better than what I've got but but
it's not even that like Trump trump not
gonna lie Trump would not bring out the
military for these riots he will I know
and even I think that was a mistake I
agree yet we're in the totalitariance
totalitarian dictatorship because they
tried to unseat a democratically elected
president it's like Ian you're like I'm
scared of Hitler quite literally Joe
Biden is trying to arrest his political
rival right now I'm scared of planets he
literally did it yeah he's trying to he
literally did arrest his life
left wing that is ruling this country
and honestly you have a fascist
religious left-wing that absolutely is
in control of this country and I'm sorry
that if my alternative and I don't think
it's as bad as that you say it is but if
it was that I would take it every day of
the week we gotta go to super chats so
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends go to
timcast.com click join us the members
only show will be at 10 pm and we will
take your calls and it'll be fun and
we'll talk a lot about this but first
let's just read all right
I'm not your buddy guy says maybe it's
just me but Beijing Biden seems to be a
Trader Who Sold State secrets and favors
to foreign powers as a Canadian I worry
about the CCP
yep yep here here that's right corec 57
says Tim how much to get you to do the
show in full vulciferon it's not it's
it's
falciferon Herald of the winter Mists
please it's like you're not gonna use
the full name you know uh it's the it's
the uh Trope character I use to
represent furry rights so if if someone
went to a workplace dressed in a full
fursuit and said their name is
vulciferon Herald of the winter Mists
and that is you have to use that name in
full otherwise it's a violation of Human
Rights
that's the example I use and literally
according to the law that's true it is
factually true yes they would they
wouldn't enforce it at this point right
like yeah you'd get laughed no no
you think so absolutely really you think
you get a lawyer represent you'd
probably get a lawyer to represent you
but I think it might also depend on what
state you're in with they would easily
they would easily uh show the law in New
York that gender expression is how you
dress and how your name is used clearly
and clearly defined as in the person I'm
wearing a fursuit it's clothing it's a
name and they would clearly establish
that furries are a long-standing
community with self-identity and so on
on what grounds under this law would
they have to exclude a large group of
people who identify in a certain way
dress a certain way and call themselves
a certain name I I don't think they
would lose that one based on this law
anyway
all right where are we at we'll grab
some more Super chats
harito says the Starbucks in Seattle
still have Windows covered in Pride
Flags yeah I'm sure that's the case of
course some of them do yeah so I think
what's happening is a bunch of specific
Starbucks are taking things down and the
union is reported union workers are
reporting it to the union and then
that's why Starbucks are like we have no
corporate policy saying that it's it's
double speak for individual stores may
be doing this Regional stores may be
doing it but from the highest level they
may not be instructing it who knows and
there can also be insubordination people
just going I'm not going to take this
flag exactly during Pride exactly
especially in Seattle I think it will
come top down and to save money and and
then certain sort of say that's not our
clientele exactly all right Joshua
Guthrie says I was in the hospital room
and the show was after oh is was that uh
is that talking about the your wife
having a new giving birth to your son oh
oh based nice good for you that's from
yesterday good for you congrats yeah
make more videos Raymond g Stanley Jr
says Tim the Bud Light effect has taken
on a life of its own now it's a
beautiful thing to see more please
that's right
absolutely
raybert G stanbert Jr okay says shout
out to you Seamus as well as other
guests like people from the daily wire
I've returned to the church and
reconnected with God due to people like
you spreading the word and being a Force
for good God bless you thank you so much
for saying that thank you so much for
saying that I'll keep you in my prayers
Matt Johnson says for Sheamus wife is
pregnant through embryo adoption I'm
sterile and she has had a medical
condition this that led to bad egg
quality curious on your position on a
case like ours after hearing your
opinion on similar stuff interesting
um so
when it comes to like embryo adoption is
he is he talking specifically about in
vitro fertilization no what happens is
it's like people that go to get in vitro
they they freeze a bunch of fertilized
eggs yeah and then people will adopt
those embryos yeah because they didn't
use them yeah it's kind of to make up
for that 90 000
um throw away uh rate that we have with
fertilizer embryos every year I'm very
big on anti surrogacy so yeah you know
so I'm not but but this is so I'm not
I'm not a fan of of surrogacy this is
something that's a bit different I
believe he's talking about the embryos
that have been created and then people
then adopting them yeah I I don't know
nearly enough about it I I really I
think and read about that I'd have to
think I've heard about it but sometimes
with these things they're just
implications you wouldn't consider when
first hearing uh right about it so I
just want to think and read about that a
lot but it's a good question I'd rather
them be adopted then thrown away and
discarded because they are each an
individual human there so I would I
would much rather do that if you know
you don't have any other options but it
also depends on if you're using a
surrogate or it's your wife's body or
whatever but uh embryo adoption is
better than
throwing them away well I have no idea
what the answer is to be honest it's a
very interesting question I want to
think about that I want to read about
that more the one free man says you pay
550 million dollars of pretend money to
build the bank Amal Bank induced
pressure caused you to foreclose on Maul
you give mall to bank build Bank dozens
of blue cities you will own nothing and
you will be happy you guys heard that in
San Francisco Westfield mall has
surrendered the property
the downtown San Francisco is gone this
is yeah because we were talking about
that hotel two hotels yeah
and now the entire Westfield mall we're
not talking Motel Six like these were
gigantic block sized hotels this is I
think it's uh several hundred thousands
I think it's 300 000 square feet yeah
it's 1.6 billion dollars worth of hotel
and this is 550 million for the
Westfield they said even right now it's
only 55 at least you know what's going
to happen
why why is the hotel going to operate no
no better question how will it operate
if the for-profit Enterprise says we
can't turn a profit on this so we're out
it's your problem now you think the bank
is going to be able to figure out how to
do it the bank doesn't it doesn't run
Hospitality businesses so what's going
to happen is they're likely going to
drop it down to a skeleton crew they're
going to eventually stop letting anybody
come at all the rooms will be will be
locked and unused because they're not
going to hire cleaning services they're
not going to want to pay for water or
heating or gas or utilities or
maintenance they're not going to be able
to keep it up to code this is
ridiculously expensive but it's not just
about what they want to do it's that if
the Hilton couldn't get customers to
come they couldn't get the money to pay
for these things the lender is certainly
not going to be able to here's what I
imagine in five years there will be a
big empty crack house the biggest crack
house you've ever seen and I'm not I'm
not being cute you're right they're
gonna they're one day there will be one
guy left and they're gonna say look he's
gonna be a senior VP at the bank they're
going to be like I don't know what we're
doing with this property we're not going
to sink anymore we're not putting good
we're not throwing good money after bad
you deal with it and the guy is going to
be sitting there and he's gonna he's
gonna be like in his office going what
am I supposed to do with this and so
he's gonna take the keys throw him in a
drawer and forget about it one day
someone's gonna walk up to the building
there's going to be homeless people
outside doing drugs as there already are
they're going to be like nobody goes in
there anymore it's been closed for
months someone's gonna smash the window
then someone else is going to walk by
and look through the smash twin don't go
inside then other people are going to
start going inside too before anyone
realizes it or cares it will be fully
occupied by random homeless drug users
absolutely so I want to make a point
here Ian you said it was 1.3 billion is
either 1.3 or 1.6 all right so this is
this is just something to seize on here
right you have
1.6 billion dollars in Lost destroyed
wealth because of bad policy forwarded
by the Democratic party in left-wing
activists and politicians are always
saying that it's criminal for one single
person to have over a billion dollars in
their Fortune but to destroy a billion
dollars that no one will ever again be
able to benefit from with respect to the
resources that have been eviscerated and
removed from the use of the people is
completely morally acceptable to them
not even something to worry about
it's gonna get crazy I say let it let it
happen that's what you get but they want
it to happen so when we sit back and say
this this is what I asked when I covered
this story earlier I said are you happy
or sad this is happening because we can
all sit here and be like I'm I'm glad
it's happening it's their policies and
they're going good I'm glad you're happy
because we did it on purpose
or should we be like we have to reject
this and try and rescue our once Great
American cities
no
I want to elaborate on this too because
my my thoughts on this and the reason I
ask the question is since the Daniel
Penny thing uh uh and Daniel Perry
uh I've been asking myself the same
question about you know abandoning
cities and people brought the point to
me saying we can't just let the act the
actual Super Chat said to me was we
can't abandon our once Great American
cities to these people this is what they
want and I thought that was a really
great point and something I probably
wasn't thinking about I do think that in
the in the short term
you're better off getting away from
cities for yourself I think in the long
term
we've got to figure out how to restore
these cities after the fact but look at
what's happening in Kensington and these
drug addicted towns right if they're
getting this like literal zombie
necrosis from shooting elephant track in
them they're they they can't even be
admitted to rehabs because they can't
deal with the wounds their their bones
are literally sticking out looks like
flesh eating diseases wait
that all goes it takes care of
themselves I'm sorry like I you know
what I mean if you're worried about
these cities and and buildings being
overrun with drug addicts eventually
that will take care of itself I don't
know about that I think you're going to
get more druggies moving into those
areas I also think that one Theory I
have I've talked about this probably two
or three times in the show so far but I
think that if they do ever repair these
cities what's going to happen is all the
people who are friends with the
political leaders will know before they
start implementing the tough on crime
policies and cleaning the place up and
they'll buy everything on the low once
the property values have been completely
Tanked
demoralize says I hope you know Trump
can't beat Biden only desantiscan if
Trump is the nominee we will vote
Democrat and Trump will lose and it'll
be your fault don't worry if DeSantis is
the nominee on voting Libertarians so I
guess we both lose no matter what
happens have a good day no
did he just wait when you said wait is
he mean the country overall or are
DeSantis voters
so many of them pretending to speak for
somebody else yeah but the like the the
Twitter DeSantis crowd they're as bad as
liberals sorry I just don't care not
every single one obviously it's it's
never every single one but I see these
tweets from people who have like they're
taking pictures in Florida with the
Santa shirts and they're lying about
everything
so they're lying so obviously I
criticized DeSantis on uh the Deep fake
thing I asked a question about this and
his policies pertaining to Jazz Jennings
and they lied about both instances
completely lied about what I said and
I'm like at this point you know what I
see from these people they are literally
just the other it's it's neocon garbage
all over again I don't trust them at all
I I uh I reached out to a disasters
official they told me that he's just
posting memes
just means it's no big deal oh they
confirmed it he was the one that posted
it no no they said they said it's just a
meme
and I was like it's a picture that says
real life Trump a collage where you you
place it's just a meme okay these people
are duplicitous they're liars and the
people supporting him go on Twitter and
make up lies all the same as the left do
in the exact same ways so when I come
out and say hello I see a problem with
this there is a video that the status
campaign put out where there's fake
images intending to manipulate people I
believe they should disavow this and say
it was wrong to do what is the response
from the DeSantis fans Tim Poole got
tricked into thinking if uh memes were
real because he's stupid which is a
left-wing tactic they use right to
obfuscate what's really going on
by all means you know the funny thing
though is like
I don't know if they think they're going
to influence me into supporting them but
I will but my only my only question is
are they actually secretly
anti-desantists and trying to make him
look really really bad on purpose
they're not I know a lot of them they're
not yeah right they're just nasty lying
people oh well no maybe they are I mean
look if you if if you wanted to get me
to campaign against DeSantis with my
utmost Vigor this is exactly how you
would do it now I can I can try and say
you know I can say something like maybe
they're actually trying to hurt DeSantis
in that capacity to get people to turn
against them but it was the DeSantis
campaign that posted the Deep fakes so
you know if they post a defects they
won't apologize for it they've been fact
checked on Twitter and now they're just
saying it's a joke it's all a big joke
then your campaign's a big joke and I
hope you lose they will they're going to
anyway the more people that enter the
field the lessons it only helps Trump
get over that hump because he has the
majority of the base so I mean and then
once you put him on the stage with Vivek
who's obviously going to clean house
with probably everyone right it'll be
Trump and then him and then he'll hook
up pick up some points and then DeSantis
will have no shot yeah DeSantis I'm
sorry so did you see the polling out of
Florida whatever it's bad yeah it's tied
with Trump so that's his home state
that's bad right they want him as a
governor a lot of people I know from
Florida is like please Ron stands for
the governor run in the future for
President we we had talked about this
before
when um I said why why would people in
Florida
vote for the guy they like to leave
right it's like they're not going to
want to be president
all right well let's uh let's let's read
some more
Ethan Reed says Starbucks is worried
about Barnes and Noble
are they
I mean maybe when's the last time you
were in a Barnes and Noble
July last weekend really yeah we did we
stopped we stopped and I read a really
good book I only go there to get like
alumni here did you post that I did uh
picture Elizabeth Warren's I read it was
really good and I'm sure she wrote it
herself we were looking at the political
books and I was like I'm willing to bet
that I can accurately predict with 90
sir I can predict with 90 certainty who
actually wrote their book and who didn't
and then there's like Elizabeth Warren
like no way I know just no way then
Charlie Kirk I'm like Charlie Kirk
definitely wrote that book so there are
certain people where you know they talk
too much like Charlie's the kind of guy
who talks so much you know he's sitting
there he's gonna write a book but before
I let some of it out no not exactly and
James O'Keefe too these are people who
are like they they have so much they
project out there Elizabeth Warren is
just like
surface level floating around she maybe
maybe she dictated some ideas to
somebody and then they wrote it out for
the history of her people I could be
wrong I could be wrong I'm not saying I
know you know that could be wrong I call
her Liz of the fohicans that's really
funny that's that's very that's very
smart actually Sheamus you're very funny
thank you I did a cartoon about it a
while ago you guys should check it out
all right we'll grab some more Super A
chats elated echo says Trump got
impeached for quote investigating his
political opponent before bite announced
what is Biden doing right now how is
this not the same it's not the same are
you nuts it's worse that's right Trump
was like I want to know what that
Biden's up to and then they're like how
dare you you're being impeached Biden
goes arrest him and they're like you got
it buddy
that's the Deep State that's the
corruption
it's getting worse worse worse
Drew outstanding in a field says
outstanding in field says thank you for
mentioning things you donate money to
Memorial Day I said I would donate to
support children of Fallen military
based on super chats just gave 1 000 to
Gary Sinise Foundation they did a great
work side note when will you announce
OCT Meetup dates and tickets
uh I have no idea
we do have like
too many people who want to come to our
October event so we're like do we need a
bigger venue now
because we probably could but yeah
it's like 850 seats so it's probably
gonna sell out we're doing a casino
again for like yeah but they didn't have
that many seats when we went to uh we
were it was a sugar house which is now I
think is a rivers or something they had
like 500 seat capacity so the original
theater we had a thousand and then we
ended up having to you know give refunds
but um
if we found a place I think uh uh what
do we have Matt Gates and Trump Jr
confirmed for it I think yes bongino
wanted to come and you know yeah I mean
because it's right there and it's easy
for them to pop by and uh I asked James
O'Keefe he said to let him know I'll ask
Patrick Bet David he said definitely
interested so I don't like if we just
bring all these people to like it's
gonna be crazy easy maybe we do another
event
I don't know around the same time we'll
figure it out
it's gonna be fun though it's gonna be
fun
Josh Branson says I feel like whenever
we're talking politics Ian just becomes
a contrarian instead of expressing his
own actual beliefs why do you think that
well you can't respond it's a super chat
I appreciate it
the elucidation I don't think that's
true necessarily no I express myself if
I really believe what I'm saying
Eric F says Ian you're a kind and gentle
person we need hard and cruel people to
fix the Deep State I know dude you also
need people that are willing to lie and
manipulate you in public on TV no of
course you do George Washington wasn't
honest with everyone all the time I feel
like you're really falling into this
like Hitler trap that I you should see
my face when you said that I was like
what is going to be a bad guy I would
love for people to think I'm I'm um
harmless also um Ian you you said George
Washington wasn't honest uh when he
chopped down his dad's cherry tree it's
true he told the truth about it he was
like a master of subterfusion and
illusion he was able to trick people
enemy troops and things like that very
good at issuing false orders to get
troop lines confused and things so you
need a deceiver if you want a really
powerful Commander I think P detail says
Ian is putting on an act for 50 000
viewers this isn't his genuine self
that's why it sounds like he's making it
up as he goes I think that it needs to
be talked about talking about Trump
obliterating the Deep state that my
point of view that I brought up earlier
it needs to be heard I'm not gonna like
ride on that hill and die on that Hill I
I'm so down to get behind a Reformation
of our government right now yeah and I
can confirm and Sheamus can confirm no
this is Ian this is the zoo Ian is this
is our buddy yeah he has these ideas uh
but that's that's kind of the point
right would it be better if we all sat
here shaking hands and petting each
other yeah we like all agreed all the
time what people need to realize too is
like me getting passionate inflamed as
Ian says something he's passionate and
flamed about and you guys thinking he's
wrong makes a conversation you know
we've we've we've always had something
like that sometimes we we agree on a lot
of things and then sometimes you know
say something like that and then I'll be
like no are you crazy and then I think
it's more fun yeah and everybody gets
along when they when it's over so well
yeah Sheamus and I have had arguments
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we've been
pretty good about not insulting each
other we're pretty good about that and
when if if and when it happens it's it
happens that day and then it's like
either we apologize or I apologize yeah
ever since you guys went to therapy
together you know it's always been like
it's like when you say obliterating the
Deep state is bad I feel like that's
incorrect are you making eye contact
with Tim because you may feel like
you're attacking him we should
I feel that when Trump says that it
seems I'm internalizing I'm from Philly
so if I insult you it's likely an
accident that's just how we talk and
it's not necessarily like on purpose or
anything oh I thought you were gonna say
I'm from Philly so if I insult you you
deserved it well that's true I mean like
no
not for worse than an insults that's
correct um yeah but so don't don't take
it personally fine so I insult people
every day in Twitter spaces tg9000 says
Ian is the Deep State they have him oh
they found me no no they didn't find you
they put you here that's Mark giadetti
says never DeSantis never Ian Trump
ramaswamy 2024. dude that would be that
would be dope that would be kind of
amazing
have you heard this guy
did you ever see that that Meme yeah
yeah wow did you hear about this guy
dude that would that would be that would
be huge a lot of people are saying like
oh I couldn't vote for Trump because
he's so bad he is but I was uh I was I
was signing this one uh older guy maybe
in his 50s and he was like I just I
can't vote for Biden man but Trump and
then I was like would you vote for
DeSantis and he was like yeah absolutely
I hope he gets it and then I was like
what if it was Trump DeSantis like
DeSantis VP and he goes
yeah yeah now I think that guy would
feel similarly with the vague the the
vague is fantastic you know someone
super chatted like why don't you talk
about Vivek I'm like we had him on
culture where it was amazing culture War
yeah I think I I think if there's a
debate Vivek will be the most
knowledgeable person on the stage
running circles around everyone but
Trump will be the most aggressive
charismatic running circles around
everyone yeah he hits hard by being nice
like he can say like really hard things
like I'm absolutely gonna pardon all the
Gen Sixers and pardon Assange and like
we're gonna go after these people but he
says it like with a kindness about him
and I'm sure that that's what's
appealing to a lot of people that
struggle with Trump even though they
have basically the same platform so the
thing that really kills me with Trump
trump is just like the little digs like
when he's like bad news very proud of
that question
[Laughter]
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and if
you really do like the show and you want
to help you can share it wherever you
can post the link in all the different
places head over to timcast.com click
join us become a member because we are
about to launch the members only
uncensored show we'll be on the front
page of the website and we'll take your
calls and talk about some spicy issues
you can find the show everywhere at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere Instagram or Twitter at
timcast Lisa do you want to shout
anything out
um just start liking and subscribing and
paying attention to the culture War
youtube.com timcast I'll also add
we're going to be putting up it's
probably gonna I mentioned this before
it's gonna turn into more of the general
timcast.com content so we've got clips
from the documentaries that are being
released we're going to be putting out
game of money on the I believe the
release date is the 20th so one week it
is a documentary by Ben Stewart about
how the financial systems work around
the world this is very very uh important
considering crypto but how the banks are
falling apart and then we do have a
documentary from Lauren Southern which
is uh it's about gun control and that
will be next month but we're gonna be
rolling out Clips at youtube.com timcast
and then Fridays at 1pm it's the culture
War
my name is Seamus Cagle and I make
cartoons at my YouTube channel it's
called Freedom Tunes we're going to be
releasing a cartoon Thursday about
Trump's trial it's going to be a lot of
fun uh we're really loving the script
and I'm excited for how it's going to
turn out if you want to watch that
subscribe on freedom tunes and if you
want to support our content and what
we're doing and the fact that we're
making animated and entertaining content
that opposes the left and it is not woke
and and keeps good uh artists who are
not woke employed go to freedomtunes.com
become a member you'll be supporting us
you'll also get an extra cartoon each
week I'm Ian cross on everyone thanks
for coming follow me Ian Crossland
anywhere on the internet Lisa you also
have Twitter it's Lisa Elizabeth correct
yes and where you host Twitter spaces I
do I host Twitter space all right or I
also jump in a lot of people's but yeah
I'm all on Twitter faces all the time
Lisa Elizabeth good to see you ma'am
thank you we got Dupre over here yep uh
that was cool to see Trump kind of in
his old uh I feel like he's up back to
those
it was nice to see him um I guess uh
just kind of recoup his uh his mantle
you know what I mean uh I'm serge.com
thanks for watching it's fun we will see
you all over at timcast.com in a couple
minutes thanks for hanging out